Okay.
So that's another issue that I'd like
to bring up because one of the things,
I cannot say grout is the alliance
between the postmodernists and the Neo
Marxists.
I can't understand the causal
relationship there because the,
tell me if you disagree with this.
Okay.
Because,
um,
I'm a psychologist,
not a sociologist and so I'm dabbling in
things that are outside of my field of
expertise and there is
some danger in that.
But the scent,
the central postmodernist claim seems to
me that because there's a near infinite
number of ways to interpret
a complex set of phenomena,
which,
which actually happens to be the case,
that you can't make a case that any
of those modes of interpretation,
our canonical,
and so if they're not canonical,
if that,
if that canonical element isn't
based in some kind of reality,
then it serves some other master.
And so the master that it hypothetically
serves for the postmodernists is
nothing but power because that seems
to be everything that they believe in.
They don't believe in competence.
They don't believe in authority.
They don't seem to believe in an objective
world because everything is language
mediated.
So it's an extraordinarily cynical
perspective that that because there's an
infinite number of interpretations,
none of them are canonical,
you can attribute it to
everything to power and dominance.
Okay.
So that,
that seemed like a
reasonable summary of the
radical relativism.
Okay.
It's a radical relativism now.
But the strange thing is despite,
okay,
and so what goes along with that is
the demolition of grand narratives.
And so that would be associated,
for example,
with the rejection of thinkers like
young and Eric Norman because of course
their foundational thinkers,
um,
in relationship to the idea that there
are embodied grand narratives that's
never touched.
But then despite the fact that
the grand narrative is rejected,
there's a neo Marxism that's tightly,
tightly allied with postmodernism.
It also seems to shade into
this strange identity politics.
And I don't,
two things,
I don't understand the
causal relationship there.
Like the,
the skeptical part of me thinks
that postmodernism was a,
was an intellectual,
it's intellectual camouflage for the
continuation of the kind of pathological
Marxism that produced the Soviet Union.
And that has no independent existence
as an intellectual field whatsoever.
But I still can't understand how the
postmodernists can make the no grand
narrative claim,
but then immerse themselves
in this grand narrative.
W W without anyone pointing out
the evidence contradictions.
Like I don't understand that.
So what do you think about that?
Well,
I can only speak about
literary and professors really,
and they seem to me almost universally
in the u s to being very naive or they,
they,
they seem to know nothing
about actual history,
political science or economics.
It's simply an attitude.
They have an attitude and it would,
in Marxism becomes simply a badge
by which they telegraph their,
um,
their solidarity with a working class
that they have nothing to do with.
Right.
I mean,
really nothing but contempt.
Yes.
And the thing is that the,
the campus leftists are
almost notorious for their,
uh,
for their rather snobbish
treatment of staff.
I mean they don't,
they don't have any rapport with the
actual working class members of the,
um,
of the infrastructure,
the janitor,
the janitors,
and even the,
even the secretaries,
there's a kind of high
and mighty aristocracy,
you know,
about these have just,
these are people who,
um,
who have wandered into
the English department.
Right.
And we're products of a time when,
um,
during the,
the new criticism they wait with when
history with history and psychology had
been excluded.
I mean,
my ambition,
okay.
Was I love the new criticism okay.
As,
as a style of textual analysis.
Right.
And,
and the,
and the new criticism had
multiple interpretations.
Okay.
That were possible.
And,
and they were encouraged.
In fact,
one of the,
you know,
one of the great projects
was made in Max series,
20th century views.
What you had at least some books.
I adored them in college and it was about
Jane Austin or about Emily Bronte or
about Wordsworth.
And they were collections of
alternate views of the same thing.
The idea that no more,
no alternative views.
And there was no relativistic
situational kind of,
kind of an interpretive
approach is nonsense.
Okay.
About,
but the point was we needed to restore
right history to literary literary study.
Okay.
And we needed to add psychology
to it because it was,
there was great animus against Freud.
And when I arrived in,
in graduate school,
in fact,
I actually went into the director of
graduate studies and protested the way
Freud and Freud and were
used as as negative terms
pay in a sneering way by that
very wasp professors.
Right.
So we need to do it.
Actually,
it seemed like we were moving there.
It can be in the early 1970s was a great
period of psycho biography about great.
About political figures.
Okay.
So I thought it's happening in all of
a sudden it all got short circuited by
this arrival,
you know,
of of poststructuralism and
postmodernism and the in the,
in the 1970s.
All right.
Um,
so I,
I feel,
I am an old historicist okay.
Not,
not a new historicist.
So I mean,
I think new stores,
so it was an absolute scam.
Right?
And it's like,
it just a way,
it's like tweezers.
You'd like just,
you know,
you pick a little bit of this,
a little bit of that,
a little bit of that.
You make a little tiny salad.
I'm going to say I'm
selling this atomize thing.
Okay.
It's supposed to mean something.
It's all can be very superficial,
very cynical,
very distance.
I like,
I am a,
I am a product.
Okay.
Of Old historicism German philology.
I decided my,
my first choice of a profession when
I was a child would was Egyptology
archaeology.
Everything I ever think about or say is,
is related to an enormous time scheme.
Okay.
From,
from antiquity and indeed
from the Stone Age.
Right.
And that is the problem with,
with these people,
they're their mouth educated,
the postmodernist and academic Marxists.
Okay.
Our mount educated embarrassingly so.
They know nothing before
the present full call.
Okay.
It's absolutely a joke
before the enlightenment.
Hey Dave,
perhaps he might be useful to people
to talk about what happened after
neoclassicism,
which by the way,
he failed to notice a lot of
what he was talking about.
Okay.
Turns out to see be simply
the hangover of neoclassicism.
Okay,
this,
this is how ignorant that man was.
I mean,
his head was,
he was not talented as a researcher.
He knew absolutely nothing.
Okay with,
you know,
nothing about antiquity.
How can you make any
kind of large structure?
While I'm large mechanism,
you know,
to analyze western culture without
knowing about classical antiquity.